un dron submarino al rescate es parte
del plan de las autoridades mexicanas
para socorrer a los 10 trabajadores que
quedaron atrapados dentro de una mina de
carbón inundada en coahuila la idea es
que el dispositivo suministrado por la
marina permite anticipar obstáculos y
riesgos para un ingreso seguro de los
buzos rescatistas pero para que esa
operación sea viable el nivel del agua
debe ser de máximo metro y medio y
actualmente supera los 19 metros que al
día de hoy se reporta un volumen de
extracción de las últimas 24 horas de
25.400 metros cúbicos es decir tenemos
un acumulado desde el 3 de agosto el
volumen total es de 70 mil
794 metros cúbicos mientras crece la
inquietud de los familiares que acusan
al gobierno de sacar provecho político y
no reaccionar a tiempo el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador ha expresado
su confianza en el éxito de la operación
y mucha fe
nos explicaban de que cuando se trabajan
esas minas los mismos mineros
hacen como
huecos refugios los antecedentes no
invitan al optimismo el año pasado siete
hombres murieron en otra mina de carbón
que colapsó en coahuila y en 2006 un
yacimiento de carbón en el mismo estado
el passat de conchos explotó por una
fuga de gas dejando 65 víctimas mortales
nuestro viendo noticia porque me imagino
este la desesperación de las personas la
angustia este si es algo muy doloroso
que lo vivimos en carne propia vale hay
en la misma fase de control veíamos a
las viudas a los hijos de nuestros
compañeros es muy triste muy doloroso la
operación de rescate no podrá ser
iniciada antes de mediados de esta
semana cuando ya se habrán cumplido ocho
días de la inundación